you folks are kind enough every week to
send in photos of things that are meant
for children boys and girls are supposed
to enjoy these things but when you look
at amigo
these are inappropriate toys this one
was sent in by gentleman did not sign
his email I didn't leave his name but he
said his kids came home with a bunch of
books that their school library was
getting rid of they were thinning the
shelves and so they gave away a bunch of
books to the kids okay and his kid
brought home this book and he said it's
no wonder they wanted to get rid of this
one this is the book his kid brought
home these book my big line is the name
of it hey I can see why they want to get
it off the shelves at school wow man
what would the prism of time makes all
the difference in that book the big lie
is the bill is not a vitamin makes you
go night-night
this next one came from Adam in Toronto
Toronto Toronto Toronto Toronto yeah he
sent this and his kid was doing a book
of connect the dots you know the connect
the dots kids yeah one two three and you
draw the dots it's the way for those of
us without any drawing ability to draw
back in the day it was colored by
numbers that was one and then was
connected dots was the other half all of
these lines idiot it'll make a dog in
this case the picture was a giraffe and
this is supposed to be what the finished
product looked like an adorable little
giraffe and so his kid was doing the
connect-the-dots version of that and he
took a picture of and sent it in he
thought maybe it might have been
inappropriate can we punch in here on
this part of the thing and no wonder the
giraffe stands so tall man I don't know
if we need that I see what they were
going for if you put them side-by-side
you see that what it really is is the
back leg of the giraffe is left behind
but still didn't someone in the during
the printing process of that book go
dick drafts got a giant [ __ ] is that a
problem for anybody that was the point
pillow rola presses never mind just
chicken and then this one comes from
Jonathan in Oceanside California down
there near San Diego he said with summer
right around the corner everyone may be
looking for a way to beat the heat and
he sent in this picture it's a giant
inflatable sprinkler the kids can run
through that is a giant six-foot unicorn
and the water gets sprayed out of the
unicorn's horn which is pretty cool he
said but don't let anyone see you blow
it up however here's a picture of of
someone blowing hey be inappropriate for
the kids to see mom belching a unicorn
get it ready for summertime
that was definitely intelligent design
the engineer built that like we have to
put the blow-up things somewhere oh I
know where should we put the nozzle what
about the [ __ ] bill just make the
connect-the-dots books
[Music]
you
[Music]